yeah detroit seems to be like
on fire right now you know just it's
about time so much
i mean listen detroit's always had
its place in hip-hop listen i'm from
phoenix we have zero place in hip-hop
we've never had nothing pop off like
it's been rough
my whole life detroit at least you know
going back to the 90s
you could you know obviously there was
always royce or eminem and then you know
dilla and you know i feel like even like
insane clown posse was from around
detroit you know what i'm saying
right so so i feel like y'all have
always had a presence in hip-hop
but but i feel like right now it feels
like a whole wave you know what i'm
saying
yeah detroit always just had like a
super underground
scene music scene like super
artists that's our own hero it's like
this our tupac that's our hot boys and
this and that
and it seemed like it never got
mainstream like
it just only would go to detroit and
other midwest cities and that was it we
should be like why like
you know dudes is it's got more money
and more jury than these rappers on tv
so
it should sound good like why the [ __ ]
we don't never you don't get there and
this just used to be like a
headache like damn well you know what's
crazy detroit and chicago
share two kind of things in my eyes as
far as like there's two sides i feel
like
to like the sonics of the city hip-hop
wise like in detroit there's
some of the illest boom bap traditional
just incredible hip hop that you ever
hear and then there's the street side of
the hip-hop scene
right and i feel like chicago is kind of
the same way like chicago is the same
city that bert chance and kanye and
common and you know what i'm saying but
on the other side there's the drill [ __ ]
like it feels like there's two separate
kind of
sounds and scenes going on in detroit
but they do kind of you know
at times come together but why is that i
mean because you know detroit is a
it's a diverse city you know you got the
street side and you got like the artsy
freestyle hip hop side right that
freestyle [ __ ] is serious out there like
it's dudes that
go to the halls and freestyle battle and
all of that like the [ __ ] on yeah you'll
be like you'll see like black milk or
guilty simpson
obviously all of that you know what i'm
saying but
we all respect each other you know what
i'm saying like it's all
love but you know detroit is a it's a
street orientated city